f
je m'appelle michael bach les jeux 48
ans je suis pompier je suis installé ici
à orléans depuis cinq ans dans cet
atelier j'ai commencé au lycée à tourner
et je crois c'est les techniques la
tournée c'est ce sont fluidité sa
rapidité a sorti les objets c'est comme
dans le dessin je peux dessiner
plusieurs formes assez rapidement je
peux changer aussi des symboles impôts à
explorer c'est avec ma exprimé assez
rapide il n'y a pas de limite avec la
terre c'est ça qui est magique aussi on
est sur la laïcité
il n'y a pas de limites comme d autres
matières on peut faire tout ce qu'on
veut
ou presque
[Musique]
e
c'est moi qui va chercher la matière
mais j'ai trouvé chaque fois j'avais
trouvé ces matières que justice était un
peu par hasard j'ai commencé à récupérer
des sables au bord de la loire pour
mélanger avec les terres aussi et ça me
donnait des textures premier monde et
aussi ce petit point fr qui font
décidément je pouvais pas contrôler et
ça ça m'a intéressé beaucoup j'ai
utilisent toujours il ya toujours un peu
du sable de la loire qui crée non mais
mélange de terre
o o
bon
je suis en train de tourner sur le mode
je vais prendre un grand morceau de
terre je peux te retourner plusieurs
pièces à la même temps sans besoin
d'arrêter et recentré chaque boule ses
manières exprimer des idées assez
rapidement pour moi
[Musique]
on
bon
je l'utilisé oui tous les éléments de
terres évidemment l'eau de l'eau qui
rendent sceptiques la quête des roches
élastique pour devenir des pros les feux
évidemment pour les cuissons et l'air
c'est moi c'est la respiration pendant
le temps où c'est aussi cette vide et je
vais dessiner donc là je vais continuer
à l'angop ça c'est l'angop j'avais
fabriqué à la base d'argile que je
récupère ça c'est le base de toutes les
pièces
on voit une pièce qui était à maillé il
ya vu le jour qui est en train de
craquer est tombé et c'est très
important pour moi ça va la terre va
exprimer
c'est si les intéressés ce souhait est
dessiné lui-même
là on est justement un dans mon espace
de recherche
c'est là que je vais travailler avec la
matière que je vais trouver dans la
nature les orgies que je trouve dans la
nature que je vais utiliser pour
formuler les englobe et les aimer il n'y
a pas deux pièces qui ressemble
exactement
et c'est ça aussi je crois l'idée
maintenant avec le travail d'artisans
c'est des gens c'est cette notion de
munich
cette idée unique que des gens il peut
partir avec une pièce